De Niro in a mob movie who'da thought
[Music]
the family so the families about Robert
De Niro and his family dinero as a
former mob guy and that's really what
the movie is the movies about them
trying to have a new life and you get
the feeling this isn't the first time
they've done this they've been relocated
a few times because sooner or later
Robert De Niro is gonna lose his [ __ ]
and beat someone with a bat who just has
a temper he's a former De Niro mob guy
and you know how that goes so if that
plot synopsis sounded kind of absurd
maybe it's because it's supposed to just
think about this movie though it's a
dark comedy and in that it really works
for this movie I enjoyed seeing this
family deal with the fact that they just
have to be normal and then once in a
while they're like you know what I'm
gonna blow up that shop because they
were [ __ ] to me because their former
mobsters you don't just lose that
imagine being a mobster you really get
your way you're used to being able to
just break kneecaps then you got to put
up with someone [ __ ] this movie really
exists for anyone who ever had to keep
their mouths shut because they're like I
am just gonna take this person shed and
okay awesome gaming for the oil change
and now all right you're replacing my
spark plugs yeah all right yeah I guess
that's just gonna cost me more money now
this movie gets to show you what happens
when someone tries to rip off a mob
family yeah it doesn't work out for them
even the kids were cool the daughters
hot as hell a little dramatic but hot as
hell and the son was awesome the sons
like one of those kids halfway through
this movie he's just running his entire
school just operationally speaking he
finds out who goes to what clique and
what and then he gets his fingers in
everything and he has all the real
estate in the school all the student
real estate which is really nothing he's
gonna graduate he's gonna be like I have
nothing good I had that now I don't cuz
I school just doesn't matter Tommy Lee
Jones is the agent whose lair I'm
keeping an eye on you guys and I'm here
for you just don't screw up doing De
Niro does he has to slap him on the
wrist and be like I said don't do that I
will say it parts in this movie you felt
like the contrast was a bit off like it
goes from okay it's clearly a comedy and
this was light-hearted and then you're
like yeah that's a dark moment granted
it's a dark comedy but I'm just saying
it's a cartoonish comedy sometimes and
there's a dark movie another thing is at
the end of the movie things are getting
really exciting and you're watching it
go down and in the end it just kind of
ends in an anticlimactic kind of way I
wanted to see more of that but it was
like gas stuff and then credits like
what does this Transformers we're doing
the really abrupt endings okay I guess
we are
sometimes when you're watching them fit
in you're like alright we're watching
the neighborly element of it all and
well sometimes it's a little boring
you know it's building up to something
and it is but sometimes it just does get
boring the movies two hours long when
you get out of it and you reflect back
it felt like two and a half I think if
they had a little bit of time management
in there they could have used to ours a
little better for the movie but in the
end I dug this movie it was a really
cool mob movie or at least former mob
movie I dug the humor I dug the dark
comedy it's not like the next Goodfellas
or anything although there is a pretty
cool Goodfellas reference in this movie
but it's enjoyable and the family is a
good time no alcohol required so if you
were in the witness protection program
or you had the opportunity to start a
whole new life where would you want it
to be where would you go whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]